bill millusion is live at the southern
border in la jolla texas what's
what are you seeing this morning bill
dana good morning to you we're seeing
what we see essentially every single
morning that we've seen out here for the
past few months take a look at this yet
another group of migrants here what's
left of a larger group
just waiting to be apprehended here
again this is something that happens
like clockwork every single day but this
comes on the heels of washington post
reporting
that the bidet administration is now
planning to offer the vaccine to
migrants as cases continue to surge here
at the border
not just within these migrants but also
within border patrol
agents so take a live look at our drone
over answers bridge in mission texas
right now we've been showing this to you
guys
all week long typically there are barely
any people under this bridge but
in recent days there have been hundreds
packed underneath there on sunday there
was well over a thousand
as this border surge showing absolutely
no signs of slowing down
here in the rio grande valley we talk
about what we see here in la jolla every
morning and every night take a look at
this video we shot out here
last evening another group of migrants
just walking up the road here once they
once they cross the uh
the rio grande they walk around the
incomplete border wall they just walk
right here to this park in la jolla
texas
and they give themselves up to border
patrol we saw some of them getting their
pulses taken some of them getting health
checks but
happens every single day take a look at
this video we shot right here
this morning this is part of that group
we just showed you in the live shot just
now started off as a much bigger group
border patrol actually telling us
in this area they apprehended more than
500 people overnight so that kind of
gives you a sense of just how many
people are streaming in here day in day
out and then take a look
at these wild photos from del rio sector
this is in the city of uvalde where
border patrol reports they apprehended
five illegal immigrants who were all
wearing camouflage and were actively
evading them they had binoculars
and had knives on them that they had
stolen from a nearby ranch house so that
kind of goes to show you there's this
criminal element as well it's not all
these family units just being willing to
turn themselves in
there are criminals mixed in and people
who are actively trying to get away
from border patrol and back out on our
drone over ansel dewis bridge
again the biden administration according
to the washington post set to start
offering covid 19 vaccines to migrants
here at the border the question
is they're offering those vaccines
they're not mandating them
it's up to the migrants if they want to
take them an ice official recently told
fox news that
30 percent of the migrants in their
custody were refusing the kovit 19
vaccine when they offered it so
we'll have to see how that plays out
we'll send it back to you and where will
they be if they get their second shot or
to get a second shot
question we might not know the answer to
yet thank you bill